in the heat of the intense battle
rengoku gives his all in an effort to
slay the upper moon three demon but to
no avail bleeding profusely ringoku in a
near death situation realizes that
defeating akasa is impossible and any
more resistance from him will end in
futility so he accepts to become a demon
and gets fed with muzon's blood by akaza
or at least this is what happened in our
version of the story but what happens
next
[Music]
being the strong human that he is it
would take him a long time before he
fully transforms into a demon he lays
unconsciously on the ground transforming
to the dismay of exhausted tanjuro and
fellow comrades who could do nothing to
stop him these short few seconds felt
like years to tanjuro as the man he
looked up to faded before his eyes it is
at this moment that akaza flees away
with rengoku in an effort to protect him
from the already rising sun the news of
rengoku accepting to transform into a
demon came as a shock to everyone in the
demon slayer core he was an easily
lovable guy and seemed to be of the
utmost conviction while the news of his
transformation spread like wildfire
people could only be seen talking about
it in hushed tones the most shocked by
the news was kagaya who considered
rangoku as his own child since rengoku
still needs to be accepted by muzon and
prove his loyalty he wouldn't make his
appearance for quite some time hence the
entertainment district arc which
featured uzui and comrades killing the
upper rank 6 and the swordsmith village
arc which saw the defeat of gyoko and
tantengu would play out the same as in
the anime
sometime later during the infinity
castle arc while all the heshira and
demon slayers battle the upper moons
rengoku who is now the upper moon 5
taking over gyoko waits for the perfect
moment to reveal himself he lurks in the
shadows knowing that his appearance will
change the tide of the ongoing battle
after an intense battle against akaza
giyu and tanjiro managed to defeat him a
feat that made them very exhausted
tanjiro faints while trying to walk and
giyu loses consciousness rengoku
continues hiding till they are awake and
have tended to their injuries it is at
this moment that rengoku makes his grand
entry right in front of two demon
slayers at first they couldn't recognize
him because he was completely different
now that he is a demon but after taking
a closer look giulio and tanjuro froze
in their tracks as they couldn't believe
that rangoku survived the demon
transformation and is now an upper rank
of the 12 kizuki
what are you guys surprised about you
look like you've just seen a ghost
what are you doing here i thought you
were dead
you coward
dismayed tangero kneels down and begs
rengoku to come back and join the demon
slayers again take a look at nezuko and
lady tamiyo they're both demons but they
still help humanity they're good and
kind to humans you can be like that too
rengoku is disappointed with tantros
groveling and mocks him for it while
also criticizing him for being too weak
to do anything against akaza during the
mujin train incident frustrated at the
failure of tonjiro's efforts to try and
win when goku back already exhausted giu
takes it upon himself to lay his former
colleague to rest
giyu being able to sense how incredibly
strong rengoku has become uses
water-breathing fifth form blessed reign
after the drought a technique that
instantly lets him decapitate his
opponents in one strike much to his
surprise rengoku appeared behind him
before he could blink and the only thing
he could feel was the pain from his left
arm which when goku sent flying in the
air that's what happens when you inhabit
that human body rengoku remarked like
the other demons he goes on and on about
how the human system is a cage and his
opponents need to be free from it
that human body of yours is useless you
will age
fatigue and sustain injuries that can
never be healed the same can't be said
about us and that's why i'm grateful to
akaza for turning me into a demon and to
muzon for accepting and introducing me
to the ranks of the upper moons his
words trigger tantro who begins to
reminisce about the mujin train incident
and how rangoku became a demon but giu's
screams bring him back to reality giyu
already exhausted and in severe pain
could do nothing but continue listening
to rangoku speaking as it is the both of
you stand no chance against me i've
honed my skills and reached the realm of
the highest
i am no longer constrained to the
limitations of the human body my flame
breathing techniques have become
exponentially more powerful one strike
from my blood demon arc could spell the
end for both of you in this sorry state
well enough of this chit chat prepare to
meet your end tomioka fire breathing
first form unknowing fire
rengoku charged towards gilu in an
attempt to decapitate him in one slash
yiyu realizing this is his final moment
decides to use his final form and most
powerful attack to block and deal as
much damage as possible to rengoku water
breathing eleventh form dead calm guil
launched a series of extremely fast
imperceptible slashes towards raging
rangoku tangero stared up in awe as the
whole place was covered in smoke as a
result of the clashes between rangoku's
and giu's attacks
after about a minute of staring at the
smoke tanjaro was surprised to see
giulio's head on the floor with rengoku
being visibly wounded this made tundra
begin to wonder and remember his last
moments with rengoku before he was
transformed into a demon and how
surprised he was when rangoku accepted
akaza's offer being enraged he took one
last stare of hatred at rangoku he hated
everything about him rangoku's
appearance irritated him transformed
rangoku had two horns on his head with
the same facial appearance but had
bloodshot eyes and sharp teeth that he
exposed at every opportunity he still
wore a cape but the pitch black one this
time having flame symbols engraved on it
a testament to his unwavering belief in
his flame breathing technique having
taken a thorough anger-filled look at
rengoku tanjuro unleashes hinukamikagura
and charges at rangoku with murderous
intent upon seeing tangero's tremendous
increase in strength with the
hinukamikagura rangoku quickly remembers
when tondro asked him about sun
breathing during the mujun train mission
rengoku however easily blocks tantros
series of hinukamikagura attacks using
fourth form blooming flame undulation a
defensive flame breathing technique
amazed at tonjiro's immense power
rangoku presents him with an offer
become a demon and surpass your human
limits when you do you will no longer
fatigue just like you did during your
battle with akaza you could go on and
train for centuries the possibilities of
what you could achieve are endless
tantra gnashed his teeth his heart
bursting with hatred towards the man he
thought of as a mentor contemplating
what his next line of attack should be
you are strong tanjiro and with your son
breathing you will surely gain a
position in the 12 kizuki and who knows
with time you may even reach the upper
rank one
hinokami kagura unboo tanjuro unleashed
a single high-powered vertical slash
towards rengoku in an attempt to
decapitate him it would take more than
that to defeat me ren goku retorted
flame breathing fifth form flaming tiger
rengoku replied with a serious stance
let's see if you can hold out against me
young kamado rengoku's attack taking a
tiger-like form flashes with tangero's
attack and they both stare intensely at
each other with their swords colliding a
series of devastating highly powerful
attacks later rengoku realizes just how
strong tanjiro has become rengoku
recognizes that he had underestimated
the injured tangero and decided to
increase the intensity of his attacks
increasing his bloodlust rangoku gives
up on trying to convince tonjiro to
convert into a demon and goes all out
for his head tanjro and ringoku both
clash swords in a spate of attacks while
clashing rengoku begins to realize that
his ongoing battle against tandro might
spell the end for him his worry grew
more and more and his desperation to
kill tantro increased ever so greatly
tondero on the other hand maintained a
very focused impression with no signs of
fatigue or giving up he carefully kept
timing calculating and countering
rangoku's attacks and moves he also
noticed rangoku's growing desperation
amid their bout i have to end him with
this attack rengoku thought while he
prepared for his strongest flame
breathing attack tondero immediately
stops when he notices rangoku take a
formidable stance he had seen this
stance before it was just before rengoku
launched his last attack as a human
against akaza this attack is going to be
incredibly powerful i'm sure he's trying
to end the battle with this last attack
he definitely has run out of options
he's a demon now in fact an upper moon
he's way stronger now of all his new
techniques this very attack he's about
to unleash should be way stronger than
when he unleashed against a kaza as a
human it's so fast that it can't be
dodged it must have overpowered
otherwise it may spell the end for me
renkoku shouted as he charged towards
tantro in a humongous dragonlike form
all tanjro could see was fire flying
towards him sun breathing dancing flash
tantro charged towards when goku faster
than the blink of an eye everybody in
the infinity castle felt the shock wave
from the collision of rengoku and
tonjiro's blades and all of them
wondered where did such an intense shock
wave come from angered at his severe
powerlessness against tanjuro rangoku
washed in dismay as his sword broke in
half and fell to the ground once again
he felt fear his eyes glanced at the
broken sword on the floor and he froze
the cold hands of death were pulling him
frustrated he let out a very loud shout
blood demon
he felt his head fall off his shoulders
sanjaro had decapitated him just before
he could unleash his blood demon art i'm
sorry that it had to end this way ringo
kuznet tantro remarked while sheathing
his blade still surprised rangoku saw an
image of his mom staring at him mom
i used my power for personal gain for my
selfish interest
i didn't protect the weak as you taught
me instead i prayed on them he kept on
crying as he felt he had broken all the
principles his mom set for him and which
he accepted and promised to uphold for
the rest of his life i was a fool i was
a selfish fool
i trusted akaza and chose demons over
humanity what was it all for
it was all for nothing tanjaro looked at
him and shook his head without saying
anything he didn't feel pity nor hatred
anymore it just felt like rengoku never
existed in the first place plagued with
regrets he was too ashamed to say any
last words to tandro as he watched him
collapse from exhaustion i hope my
decisions and actions don't spell the
end of the demon slayer core were his
final thoughts before completely
disintegrating into thin air the
remaining demon slayers and hashira
battle muzan kibutsuji in the absence of
tanjuro and giyu little did they know
that giu was dead and tundra had passed
out from the battle with rangoku some
time later chandra regains consciousness
and rushes to the battle scene but by
the time he got there most of the demon
slayers had been wiped out by the demon
king muzon the last standing hashira
guiome turned around and gave a smile to
tanjro before having his head pulverized
by muzan having lost all hope and being
extremely weak and exhausted from
fighting two upper moons tanjuro falls
to his knees and starts crying sensing
the same aura as yorishi's in tanjiro
muzon gives him a harsh glare and
unhesitantly blitzes off his head who
would have thought that rangoku's
decision would result in this outcome
the end of the demon slayer core muzon
thought in deep appreciation for akaza
and rangoku click on this video where we
explained all future hashira and demon
slayer don't be shy click it